The grammar of graphics was not created purely for
logistical reasons though it does have that nice side effect of not having to
repeat work if specifications change.
By separating the underlying data from the means of presenting that data,
you can think separately about each visual element and the structure and
form of that data.
This allows us to both transform and manipulate our data without having to
worry about the visual representation and what might get messed up.
And the last great effect I'll go over of separating our
data from the visual presentation of that data is to allow for
very interesting collaboration across teams.
Let's say possibly between a designer who works on
the visual aesthetic separately from developers or
engineers who might work on transforming and merging data.